[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute gibt es ein richtig
leckeres und vor allem leichtes dessert
denn nach dem fastenbrechen nach dem
iftar mächte man ja sich nicht vollhauen
mit irgendwelchen süßkram sondern man
möchte einfach so schön das leichteste
abgang essen und da machen wir jetzt
einen locker leichten pudding auf die
türkische art auf die typische art damit
ist gemeint dass es manchmal auch keine
rein kommt auf türkisch heißt es
mohammed und ich habe jetzt ein paar
zutaten schreibe ich euch wie immer
unten im die infobox und da haben wir
unter anderem hier milch ein bisschen
zucker wir binden mit mehl und
speisestärke und dann kommt noch ein
bisschen vanille exakt dazu und ich gibt
es hier direkt ich habe jetzt jemanden
hoch anfangen können natürlich auch
einen topf nehmen gebe es einfach alle
zutaten reinverlust klümpchen frei
schaltet dann den herd ein und dann
lassen wir das unter ständigem rühren
einmal aufkochen und eindecken
[Musik]
so und jetzt habe ich den pudding einmal
eindecken lassen und ich mache jetzt
folgen das werde die hälfte hier einmal
in meinen gefäß renten und die andere
hälfte werde ich noch mit der ouvertüre
verfeinern dann habt ihr nämlich direkt
zwei varianten ja gut das war nicht ganz
die hälfte so ein bisschen mache ich
noch
was muss auch nicht genau so macht es
einfach pi mal daumen da kann nämlich
nichts schief gehen denn die haben wir
jetzt noch die rest sitze und das
schmeckt einfach die schokolade drin
beziehungsweise die kuvertüre
[Musik]
ein pudding ein bisschen zu lange im top
mann soll ihm schon direkt von der herd
fläche ziehen sobald es eingedeckt ist
las dies zu lange stehen oder rührt ihr
auch nicht regelmäßig dann kann es
passieren dass die milch so ganz ganz
leicht anbrennen und ihren diese
klümpchen habt in dem fall gerne einfach
durch ein haarsieb streichen und dann
ist auch alles wieder gut ich mache es
jetzt so dass ich auch wenn ich das
welche waren weiterverarbeitet dass ich
einfach frischhaltefolie auf die
oberfläche gebe damit sich keine haut
bildet wobei es soll ja auch leute gehen
die mögen haut kann überhaupt nicht
verstehen könnt ihr in die kommentare
schreiben und wir machen weiter mit den
restlichen zutaten so ich legte jetzt
los mit dem christa ziehen und ich bin
einfach dass christa ziehen als sehr gut
zusammenpassen mit dem podium und gleich
nämlich auch noch kekse mit diese
karamell kekse und da bin ich jetzt
einfach frische pistazien ohne schale
die verlinkt ich euch gerne die sind aus
gaziantep aus meinem job und die werde
ich jetzt einfach grob hacken die könnte
auch malen wenn dir vielleicht werde ich
sie malen für später für die deko aber
ich glaube für den boden um so schicht
des jahres werde ich die pro packen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so die karamatic so habe ich jetzt
einfach mit ein bisschen wut okay so
viel wut habe ich heute ich glaube es
war eher sanft habe ich so einfach klein
gemacht und zerbröselt ihr könnt auch
ein mixer leben aber ich wollte euch
einfach zeigen dass falls sie kein habt
dass das auch so funktioniert so fertig
und dann machen wir jetzt einfach weiter
mit den erdbeeren sind die passen
nämlich auch wunderbar dazu und die
werde ich einfach grob würfeln ich werde
auf jeden fall ein paar schöne für die
deko beiseite stellen damit die auch
noch oben drauf kommt und was ich dann
noch mache ist einfach nur der
einfachheit halber das muss sie auch
nicht unbedingt ist dass ich den pudding
in spritzbeutel viele freunde die spitze
abschneide dann kann man sie nicht
einfach schöner dekorieren dann wird das
ganze geschichte und dann sind wir auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]
so und fertig ist unser leckeres dessert
und das ist wirklich eins was so gar
nicht schwer im magen liegt man hat die
frischen früchte ihr könntet auch andere
früchte nehmen man hat einfach diesen
locker leichten pudding und die
pistazien obendrauf und unten drunter
fand ich auch können sie es mit denen
karamell klickten dass man einfach noch
sowieso eine kleine überraschung am ende
hat und ja lasst es euch auf jeden fall
schmecken macht unbedingt nach und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten rezept zur
diesjährigen ramadan rey und ihr dürften
auch sehr gerne unten in die kommentare
schreiben was ihren immer gerne so als
dessert ist was präferiert ihr da
schreibt mir das mal gerne lasse ich
mich auch nur von euch inspirieren und
würde dann einfach sein bis zunächst 1
[Musik]
[Applaus]